the twelve boys rescued from a cave in
Thailand are reported to be feeling
better this morning the boys and their
soccer coach have been hospitalized
since their 18 day ordeal ended earlier
this week and a Warner is outside that
hospital in chiang rai thailand with new
information about their rescue and a
good morning good morning well the
British divers who found those boys they
had a helper inside the cave a student
who was able to take a leadership role
by translating for them well today staff
at his school told me that is not a
surprise to them they say this is a
young boy who's already faced
significant challenges in his life and
overcome them teacher crew nice says 14
year old a dune salmon has always been a
leader despite the fact he doesn't have
his parents with him or even an official
home since a dunes parents slipped him
out of Myanmar eight years ago to escape
the ethnic conflicts there he's become
one of many students at this school
considered stateless not a citizen of
Thailand or any other country yet here a
dune is a top student and a standout
athlete I was so worried who told us but
a dunes proficiency in languages he
speaks for proved key inside the cave as
he acted as translator for the British
divers during the complicated rescue new
images show responders carrying the boys
through the caves they were given
anti-anxiety medication to keep them
calm in some portions of the journey the
boys were put into harnesses lying down
rescuers used a rope system and
highline's to pull them through the
caverns before they were found a family
member tells CBS News the boys work
together to survive for nine days in the
cave when the boys entered the cave they
each had a flashlight
they had one watch and one mobile phone
with light until the batteries died they
were able to check the watch for the
time for the first three days they slept
close together for warmth and took turns
digging in the cave to try to redirect
the water that had trapped them now the
boys are in the hospital where a new
video shows them
sitting up in their beds they're
relieved parents watching them through a
window it's the result a dunes teacher
has been waiting for oh he's a miracle
boy she told us I'm so happy that he is
safe so Thai Airways has now announced
that it will be providing round-trip
tickets plus a week-long
all-expenses-paid trip back to Thailand
for all of the international volunteers
who helped out on this rescue meanwhile
Thai officials say that they want to
establish an interactive museum at the
cave site featuring items like clothing
worn by the rescuers but for now Nora
the cave is closed
yeah the cave is closed understandably
something has still a lot of interest
and a Warner thank you so much for all
that reporting